welcome to this video playing refx for
an exfil from i think this is estonia at
stony aright you have the French what ok
let's do 93 m I play don't play that too
often simply because um I don't know
Bishop before wall but he's playing age
6 which is a very em under conventional
line but it's not so bad actually not
sure that in IDF six is played him but I
came interesting yeah well probably five
him
yeah just be sure to probably em stuff
to do without this sometimes you canjust
castle in this kind of structure and
give up the pawn but here I'm not sure
just play it simple yeah this is a
playable position for Blackie no doubt
about it mmm yeah remarkable what kind
of lines them are playable mmm what am i
doing now
maybe just castling not sure though yeah
black can just take play 96 and have a
good position but some just like that or
queen a five for example hmm this I'm
not sure about really it looks very slow
okay all this this must be the right
move everything else just looks too slow
try to open up in the center ok so now
here yeah I can Queen takes their ass e4
and e5 this should be quite nice so pawn
takes was probably going to be played
and then at least I'm I'm a managed to
get rid of my of my my double porn maybe
taking and ce4 I am exactly and then you
cannot move the pawn because I'm Bishop
before that's very good d for Bishop
before we should be seven I have rugby
one okay yeah that looks quite ok then
threatening to take on d5 of course yes
this is what this is some move that you
can play of course queen e 2 so that you
still cannot take maybe I'll Quincy to
Quincy to be one not sure much Quincy
296 00 ke so gayi go here if he takes on
c4 I play Bishop before this was the
idea but ok I'll simply recapturing it's
not bad actually okay now d for the
screen if also i can or the other work
maybe the other rock
so d for you cannot play and capturing
he also cannot play and I'm threatening
now to take this is not so easy to
handle for black this situation on the D
file very important of course is d4
Queenie form threatening made on edge
seven and threatening the knight on c6
yes well here I can take and play Bishop
age seven at least I can do that maybe I
have some some better some better a
better way take it hmm yeah bishop age
some nights not like terribly bad but
does not feel like like being the best
move really you came I'll start with
that Bishop before us also also a
possibility i guess i need to eat
something um ok Bishop b4 maybe cam
Fisher page seven looks a bit strange so
let's try to centralize the Queen
I am is this a check yeah but it is in a
way so probably I need to do this anyway
also attacking on c5 of course p.m. yeah
I guess night g6 I have rook c6 Luke c6
I guess on twin f5 yeah it looks it
looks right anyway so Roxy 6 queen bee
70 p 1 is no problem yeah that looks
quite nice question is queen e 70 maybe
Queenie 7
just again attacking you five and John
I'm not I don't have much time that
don't really see that I was getting so
low okay let's speed up a bit position
is still quite okay as the pawn on c6
and c5 is a weakness and they have this
advantage in space me6 also just take
that hi morning I played another
technical more technical manner I can go
to a form i completely forgot about that
okay yeah well at least he cannot take
h5 because of G for winning a piece I
can maybe you can look now we cannot
okay but this wasn't the intention of
all of that but still okay probably
probably I just I just had forgotten
that he can that he can go to UM to f3
yeah the the rook trade I get very
quickly to see five so i don't think the
king and porn endgame was a problem
check
f3 was patent okay rook t4 there's King
takes a c5 but I should have done that
then done that earlier
check yeah okay you cannot play so
precisely with a couple of seconds on
the clock it's simply simply not easy to
do check check yeah I really this night
a former killed me white resides at
least at least from a practical point of
view Mia widest is just better in many
ways I can take c5 everything is ok but
I just I forgot that she can can go to
air form and this is really not helping
yeah we can just go here and had
forgotten that simply thought you needed
to retreat like f 8 OS 7 and 9 mm f4 is
just better so this is this really
spoiled all of whites advantage that
probably I mean there must be some way
to improve earlier because this this
just looks terrible yeah probably as
though should have done this bishop age
72 check prom this song check
yeah maybe I should have done that hmm
the the important thing is that the king
is so misplaced on age 7 I always have
this checks available like check here
check on see to check on e form and this
is very important for all the technical
little things now this is probably what
I needed to do I mean there must be some
way to to use this year this p 6 and so
on this was just not not good but it was
still fairly resilient this is right it
should be six is also ok and now here i
need to do something well this was also
okay and now here I am I must I must
play this check this is not bad but it's
not it's not as convincing really yeah
and here somewhere around here there's
certainly a ways to improve things e 6
is also quite interesting just pushing
the porn yeah but my problem really was
that the the night air for I absolutely
didn't see and now with 50 seconds it's
it's tricky to play we had to check I
had 11 village this is bad really really
bad this idea f three kings before I
only saw a bit later if I do this now
it's a fits okay I think like here and I
can also get the rook over I think this
should be okay I'm quite active here and
let's say if you protect this root comes
to a success should be in order should
be really all right 22 probably keep
keep it about equal but now the king is
just too quick and I can only hope for a
miracle here you played this nicely from
a technical point of view
didn't check she didn't get any any
chance so after that alright thanks for
watching